hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast can ai-powered
diagnostics revolutionize
anti-microbial stewardship machine
learn-based prediction of anti-microbial
resistance
in short and long read sequencing data
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by op gen and
aries genetics an objen group
company revolutionizing how we address
the global challenge of antimicrobial
resistance with innovative genome
technologies and ai powered
bioinformatics for more information
about our sponsor please visit their
site at optgen.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply report your problem by clicking
on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr rna
materna a managing director and the ceo
of aries genetics
and objen group company for a complete
biography of our presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top right
side of your screen dr materna welcome
you may now
begin your presentation sir
hello thank you for tuning in to this
presentation my name is anne materna and
i'm the ceo of aries genetics and over
the course of the next 30 minutes i will
speak about how machine learning when
combined with sequencing based solutions
can overcome key limitations in
infectious disease testing and
surveillance
a few words up front about aries
genetics we are a vienna based startup
founded in 2017 and together with
creators we are part of the option group
of companies
together we fight against antimicrobial
resistance through cutting-edge
molecular microbiology
while option and curators deliver
regulatory approved molecular
diagnostics for antibiotic resistant
pathogens
aries genetics is where we harness
genomics and innovative machine learning
approaches
to address the global threat of
antimicrobial resistance or amr
let's begin with a few facts on amr
while the attention of many of us quite
rightfully is on the impact of the
current covit-19 pandemic
another severe pandemic is on the rise
antibiotics which we all have come to
rely upon
as effective treatment of otherwise
often dangerous and sometimes deadly
infections
are slowly but steadily becoming
ineffective
we see a global increase in pathogens
that prove resistant against standard
and even last resort
antimicrobial therapy with already tens
of millions affected by amr
and dozens of billions of euros per year
in direct healthcare cost
the most severe consequence we face are
over
700 000 fatalities each year that is
over 2 000 per day
by some estimates these numbers are
expected to rise to 10 million per year
by 2050 meaning the mr epidemic
would eclipse cancer as the leading
cause of death
the problem of amrs exacerbated by the
challenge of choosing the right
treatment
predicting how an infected patient will
respond to antibiotic therapy is a hard
problem
influenced by factors such as the
genomics of the pathogen that is causing
the infection
as a consequence only a minority of
patients are receiving appropriate
treatment
a fact that has become apparent once
more in the overtreatment of kovit-19
patients with antibiotics to quell
bacterial co-infections
in case you wonder why overtreatment is
a problem it is probably worthwhile to
take a look into what is actually
causing amr
as any microbial ecologist or
microbiologist will explain you
antimicrobial compounds or antibiotics
are produced naturally by microbes
themselves in order to compete with
other microbes inhabiting the same
ecological niche
in response to these compounds microbes
evolve the very mechanisms that cause
resistance and give us trouble in the
care of infectious disease patients
inappropriate antibiotic use for example
overuse or simply using the wrong
antibiotic for a pathogen
then selectively enriches for microbes
that have evolved such resistance
mechanisms
and whenever this situation is met with
imperfect hygiene and infection
prevention
then we face the risk of enriching for
and spreading
antibiotic resistant or even multi-drug
resistant pathogens
and that in turn requires increased
antibiotic use fueling the cycle
the question therefore is what can be
done to break this vicious vicious cycle
leading to amr
on one hand we'll rely on the
pharmaceutical industry to keep
developing novel forms of antibiotic
therapy
the challenge for pharma thereby is that
new drug development becomes a race
against the evolution of resistance
mechanisms
this of course is a very tall order
while
an encouraging number of 70 drugs is
currently in different stages of
clinical and pre-clinical development
the who just noted in its recently
released 2020 report and antibiotic drug
candidates
that this number may not be high enough
to tackle amr as currently over
80 percent of newly approved drugs can
be readily rendered ineffective by
existing
resistance mechanisms this does however
not mean defeat
the improved and improved antimicrobial
stewardship can help us regain the
advantage over amr
antimicrobial stewardship refers to
technologies and interventions that
promote the optimal use
and avoid the overuse of antibiotics now
why is this important
as i try to allude to when addressing
the cause of amr
appropriate use of antibiotics was shown
not only to improve patient outcomes but
also to reduce the
emergence of antibiotic resistance
and this is where technology can help us
make the difference
in order to inform and promote
appropriate antibiotic therapy
and to enable antibiotic stewardship we
need on one hand solutions that diagnose
or predict resistance to enable
targeted therapy with appropriate
antibiotics as well as solutions that
enable the global surveillance for amr
to allow us to detect outbreaks to
counter them with infection prevention
measures and to empirically inform
first-line antibiotic selection
let's take a look at the technologies
that are in the clinic today
the standard of care in infectious
disease diagnosis are bacterial cultures
which are routinely used for the
identification of infective agents and
the
determination of suitable antibiotic
treatment options
whenever a culture is positive meaning
if if a pathogen
if pathogen growth is present then
antibiotic susceptibility testing
also referred to ast is performed in
order to determine which antibiotics are
effective and which will likely be met
with resistance
while these culture-based methods are
being considered the gold standard they
are often
labor intensive and may miss difficult
to culture pathogens
turnaround time ranges from one to three
days
or more which is long considering that
patients with acute infections
require urgent care often within hours
this lack of sensitivity and speed is
addressed by modern molecular tests
relying on pcr
leading pcr panels such as the tests
available on the curator's universe
system
achieve very high sensitivities and can
return results in a matter of hours
even pushing the limit below one hour
however these systems can only screen
for up to a few hundred biomarkers at
best
this means each assay which has to be
individually developed validated and
potentially approved
can cover a limited number of pathogens
and for each pathogen
only a limited number of genetic markers
for amr
given that today the number of genetic
markers for amr is measured in the
thousands
the question has to be is there a system
that could simultaneously and
comprehensively screen for any pathogen
and all known genetic markers for
antibiotic resistance
and what if the system would not only
report the detected amar markers
but also emulate the advantages of
culture by predicting whether
detective pathogens are susceptible or
resistant to antibiotic therapy
this is where next generation sequencing
or ngs enters the picture
ngs is increasingly adopted by clinical
labs and its utility
for example for microbial typing and
epidemiology is already undisputed
it is the first technology that thanks
to an enormous sampling depth is not
only
very sensitive but also captures the
entire genome
allowing for an exhaustive
characterization of genetic amar markers
in a single test
moreover such comprehensive genomic
information
provides a chance to use ai and
predictive modeling
to emulate culture-based ast and predict
which antibiotics represent suitable
treatment options
with sequencing costs and turnaround
times rapidly decreasing
trying to overcome the shortcomings in
the current standard of care through
sequencing based predictive
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
has therefore firmly emerged as a focus
for aerys genetics
allow me to share with you some of the
key challenges but also the milestones
we've met on our mission to
revolutionize infectious disease testing
next
once our objective had been set on
enabling accurate and fast detection of
pathogens and the prediction of amr
we started to address potential
roadblocks very quickly databases for
amr markers
emerged as a critical technological
component
when we evaluated several public america
databases for their suitability
for predictive ast we recognized a
number of shortcomings
here two examples the annotation of
amr markers at the level of antibiotic
classes
was two cores for machine learning
considering that different antibiotic
compounds
within the same class are affected
differently by any given amr marker
for example because of different
enzymatic affinities
therefore raising the resolution of
marker annotation from antibiotic class
to the level of antibiotic compound
substantially improved predictive
modeling
in addition simple rule-based models for
individual markers tended to over
generalize
because multiple genetic factors can for
example synergistically or
antagonistically contribute to the mr
phenotype
we needed to adjust for biology and
allow for polyvary predictive models
based on these and other findings we
decided to develop airsdb
a comprehensive amr knowledge base
designed from ground up to
enable predictive ast rs2b today is a
globally leading database of curated amr
markers and information about resistance
derived from genotypic and phenotypic
data
what sets arsdb apart from other
databases is not only comprehensiveness
but that it also harbors a continuously
growing collection of clinical pathogen
genomes and associated validated ast
measurements
that determine how any given pathogen in
this database has responded
phenotypically
in the lab when exposed to a wide range
of antibiotics
this additional data layer offers two
unique benefits
these genotype phenotype data
associations
can be used for machine learning more
specifically to train predictive models
that not only discover novel biomarkers
for amr
but that can predict how pathogens
respond to therapy based on genomic data
a process we refer to as predictive ast
or pasd
at aeros genetics currently the models
to predict antibiotic susceptibility are
trained as stacked ensemble models
on ast results and on a variety of
genetic markers including k-mers
gene and protein annotations and others
all collected within the rsdb
this model-based approach can then be
complemented by a rule-based approach
taking into account the interplay
between
multiple resistance mechanisms and
antibiotic compounds
as the figure in the middle illustrates
we not only rely on the presence
absence of certain resistance genes but
we also consider
changes in non-coding regions of the
genome as well as novel markers
that our predictive algorithms have
discovered
allow me to introduce over the next
couple of slides how we use rsdb
and predictive modeling to enable a
number of sequencing based solutions for
amr and pathogen detection
and how we validate the performance of
these solutions
the resolution spectrum today includes a
number of next generation sequencing
services
and software central to our offering is
and remains
the proprietary rsdb this database
database powers
both rsiss our service for bacterial
isolate sequencing
as well as the newly introduced areas
upa
arres upa is not the focus of this
presentation today but i will say that
it is a target enrichment ngs panel
that comprehensively covers pathogens as
well as thousands of genetic markers
we have selected from the rsdb this
essay is currently
used in collaboration with five early
access customers in the public health
space in five different countries
and finally the iris cloud on the right
side is a cloud-based user-friendly
interpretation and reporting software
which enables our own ngs service lab
and is available to other ngs labs
we demonstrated in several studies the
high categorical
categorical agreement between standard
of care results
with the resistance phenotypes we
predicted based on ngs data using
predictive ast
these studies include for instance the
first into our knowledge only
multi-center evaluation
that is successfully demonstrating the
feasibility and performance
of predictive ast for 13 pathogens
causing lower respiratory tract
infections
some of the study results are shown here
and i apologize for the data-rich nature
of this slide
the matrix shows along the horizontal
axis the samples for the various
pathogens
reported by the standard of care the
vertical axis
lists the different antibody compounds
by compound class
that were tested for the intersections
or the fields in this table
show the categorical agreement in
percent between aries predictive ast
and culture if you now exclude
all pathogen drug combinations for which
pathogens are
intrinsically resistant those are the
ones here in blue
and those in gray for which the standard
of care method did not detect any
resistance
then the remaining white fields
oops sorry
then the remaining white fields on the
table are the areas in which
a direct comparison of rspasd and
culture based ast is possible
as the green fields indicate or be able
to demonstrate high concordance
reaching for most of the pathogen drug
combinations values significantly above
the regulatory threshold for ast devices
of greater than 90
and achieving up to 100 studies like
these are not only important for
clinical validation purposes
we also embrace them as they give our
data science teams clear indicators
on which passage and drug combinations
to focus our efforts on for predictive
model development
and for database curation
encouraged by these findings and to help
translate this technology into
applications
we have more recently validated the
entire end-to-end workflow
from sequencing of isolates on illumina
the de facto standard ngs platform
all the way through the data
interpretation via irsdb
and rs cloud using our ai-powered
bioinformatics pipeline
the workflow performance was very robust
in terms of
repeatability reproducibility
sensitivity and specificity
reaching consistently 100 for pathogen
identification
multi-local sequence typing and
genotyping and values in the high 90s
for amr market detection we
we did actually apply clear standards
for to the validation process and we
published both performance as well
as validation protocols in order to make
iris technology portable to other ngs
laboratories
so in conclusion the use of rsdb
which everyone can access through the rs
cloud portal enables the highly accurate
reproducible analysis of bacterial
isolates for
pathogen identification typing and the
comprehensive and prognostic
characterization of amr
both studies that i just mentioned are
once more referenced here at the bottom
of the slide
the question for rs genetics at the
moment is
can this technology be applied to
further increase
the utility and affordability of ngs
based surveillance
by relying on faster and lower cost ngs
methods
next i will give you a glimpse into
ongoing work
to enable the use of the promising
nanopore sequencing technology
as you probably know antimicrobial
stewardship and improved empirically
informed treatment
with the right antibiotics depends on
global surveillance for pathogens and
amr
to make sure the pervasive use of
surveillance technologies
is also available to low to mid-income
geographies
which often act as reservoirs for mr
outbreaks
these technologies must of course be
accurate but they also must be fast
so local clinicians benefit from you
from using them they must be affordable
they must be deployable and usable in
low complexity labs available in these
in these countries the sequencing
platform by oxford nanopore technology
or omt satisfies the requirements for
speed
low cost portability and workflow
simplicity
it therefore has the potential to be a
platform of choice for fast
pathogen identification amr detection
and predictive ast
the critical questions question however
is if
ont accuracy is sufficient to enable all
these applications
or if some for example pathogen typing
will be impacted by the accuracy
ont platforms perform real-time
sequencing of long individual dna
molecules
to accomplish this life enzymes unwind
and translocate a single strand through
a biological pore and across a membrane
a steady flow of ions through this pore
results in a measurable current
and when threading the dna through this
pore then depending on the base
composition that is currently blocking
the pore
in other words the sequence this flow of
ions is more or less blocked
leading in leading to measurable drops
in current these current drops
occur in sequence specific patterns as
some bases lead to stronger or weaker
longer or shorter changes in current
the advantages of this method include
low cost speed
long read length and a couple of other
interesting aspects such as the
potential to
directly sequence rna or to detect
chemical dna modifications
such as dna methylation a potential
issue however is that biological poor
and dna translocating enzymes
are likely to be not 100 identical
across all pores
and flow cells biological variability is
unavoidable and
potentially affects base calling quality
we are therefore currently conducting a
validation study
using the ont platform relying
on the same seven ground truth reference
strains we have used previously
in our published validation studies
this slide outlines the study design the
seven
samples were extracted with suitable dna
extraction methods from three different
vendors resulting in a total of 21 dna
extracts
each extract is aliquoted and sent to
three partner labs
for ngs library preparation and
sequencing at an insert size of 10 kb
using ont rapid barcoding kits and the r
10.3 flow cells
raw data are then uploaded to the iris
cloud and subjected to the standard
analysis workflow
which consists of qc de novo assembly
microbial identification
core genome embolicity amr marker
prediction predictive ast and plasma
typing
preliminary data and these are truly hot
of the press suggest a fair amount of
variability in terms of output
and read quality between partner labs
nevertheless basic nucleotide identity
between the resulting genome assemblies
and the ground truth remain high and
this is an important prerequisite for
downstream analyses
it's also important to note that the
number of sequencing errors
from ont when compared to illumina
consistently increases three to
four-fold
the question we are therefore focusing
on is if and to what extent
does this drop in base quality affect
pathogen identification
the characterization of amr and so on
here you see a deeper dive into
sequencing statistics for two out of the
seven samples
compared compared between illumina here
highlighted in in blue
and across the partner labs again
differences between illumina and ont
sequencing as well as variability across
partner labs becomes apparent when
looking at sequencing depth
average contact length number of
identified coding sequences
gc content completeness and
fragmentation
um yet if you focus on the right most
chart then you can see that the quality
of the resulting genome assembly
remains with tier high very high across
the majority of samples and labs which
is a
key criterion for good analytical
performance on the irs cloud
so these results were very now very
encouraging
i will conclude with a preview of the
data interpretation
in interpretation on iris cloud which as
i mentioned uh
is very encouraging shown here are
values for accuracy
measured in percent concordance and
reproducibility
in summary the arrs ai powered analytics
consistently reach 100 percent for
pathogen id
up to an average of 96 percent for amar
market detection
and with up to 100 even higher values
for the prediction of phenotypic
resistance
of the ont sequenced isolates
first data on plasmid typing suggests
that ont is at least on par with
illumina which is to be expected from a
long read method
however the verdict is still out on
cordino mst
however given the fraction of genetic
loci that are included in the schemes of
core genome memoricity that are for a
pure discordant between the ont
assemblies and known alleles already
hint at mlst as possibly the only
achilles heel we may have discovered for
this otherwise very promising platform
allowing for the rapid and
cost-effective detection
and surveillance of pathogens in amr and
with that
i'd like to conclude thank you for your
attention
and invite your questions
and thank you dr marterna for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
dr martina the performance of the
isolate
sequencing workflow is very impressive
however
i however missed your definition of the
reproducibility and repeatability could
you
please remind me of how both were
defined
of course i'd be happy to i hope you can
hear me well
still yes okay then the repeatability
is defined as what we're measuring in
both cases precision
for the repeatability we're measuring
the precision within runs
whereas for reproducibility we're
measuring the precision
between runs thank you so much
and our next audience member says we're
excited to hear
that aries genetics is publishing
validation protocols for the isolate
sequencing workflow to support
other labs in the adoption of ngs we are
planning to establish
ngs capabilities in our lab next year
do you offer some kind of services that
would help labs
with the setups of this or similar
flows that that's an interesting
question
thank you for for asking that um
the exact answer to this question
depends a bit on
the the exact needs but of course the
reason for publishing performance
results
and validation protocols for the entire
workflow so from sequencing all the way
to analysis
is of course to make it easy for any lab
to adopt
isolate analysis or predictive asd
within their own ngs facilities and to
produce the results of the same quality
by using the aerys cloud for
for data analysis now if
if your lab for instance pursues clear
registration or cup accreditation
then the validation burden remains with
your lab
but what we offer is for instance
parallel sequencing of validation
samples
in our lab and the client lab to help
detect
and resolve any discrepancies
pre-pre-validation
thank you so much now emr
profiling and predictive ast especially
in samples
we collect for infection prevention is
very interesting
and we would like help and would it
would it help us
to improve empirical selection of
antibiotic treatments
how can our microbiology lab
access the aries db
the air sdb is easily accessible through
the aries cloud actually one of the
reasons we've developed the aries cloud
is to offer easy access to this database
ares cloud is a very user-friendly and
web-based
analysis and reporting portal portal
which by the way is used by our own ngs
service lab
and is designed such that other labs as
well
can completely automate the entire
analysis and generate reports
for example for isolate sequencing the
analysis
includes for instance data qc the novel
genome assembly
pathogen identification
mlst or multi-locus sequence typing and
core genome mst
and of course the the very comprehensive
amr profiling and predictive ast that
the the aerosdb is known for
thank you so much dr matteon and i also
want to thank our audience members for
these great questions
coming in has aries investigated the
pack bio
platform for long read
very good question another very
interesting um single molecule long read
platform
no not in any extensive validation
studies yet
um that of course is um is something
that could be of interest i
i'd like to point out that uh bio um
has been has been around i believe uh
somewhat longer than the platform
we're investigating now um however
is less portable and is therefore
and also more costly and is therefore
less suitable
for deployment in low-to-mid income
geographies which as
which as i mentioned are very important
for surveillance efforts as
these countries are often most heavily
impacted by
amr outbreaks thank you so much
and what is next for aries and how would
we participate
if we are interested in this technology
um another wonderful question what's
what's next for aries is of course to
offer
access to the database uh through um
through the iris cloud which is a
software as a service model
um but we have established a vienna
based
ngs service lab in which we support
customers in clinical microbiology with
surveillance needs
but also customers in the pharmaceutical
space
who are developing novel antibiotic
therapies with
contract research or with standard
sequencing of isolates or native patient
samples
something that i did not mention today
but i'll use this opportunity
is that we also explore the the rich
content
of genetic markers for amr in the rsdb
uh in order to develop a target capture
or target enrichment
based ngs assay
suitable for a culture for the
culture-free detection of pathogens and
amr
in native patient or environmental
specimen so if you're interested or in
need of any of these solutions please
don't hesitate
to get in touch and you can reach us for
example through email to
services ariesgenetics.com
thank you aries
dot genetics uh sorry hold on one second
let me
quickly spell out the rather long email
address for you
it is services at aries
minersgenetics.com
thank you so much dr materna we have
time for one more question
have you tried snp analysis
instead of cg mlst
oh snip analysis yes yes that's a very
good question
um the i believe these two these two
methods
can serve slightly different purposes
and we use both
the routine pipeline that we perform on
any isolate that we receive
includes mlsd and core genome mlst uh
snip on it
and and and this is a for those of you
who are not that familiar with this with
this
type of analysis this analysis will
genotype
um isolates or strains of of of a
certain pathogen
and return a a nomenclature that allows
epidemiologists or clinical
microbiologist
um to take note of of a pathogen that
has been detected
in the network and associated with maybe
an ongoing outbreak or
recognize it as a new outbreak so this
nomenclature is
is very useful um to quickly identify
what's what is going on
snip analysis is actually more powerful
as you're really
using the entire genome and the
acquisition
of individual point mutations that that
occur
from the initial outbreak
of this pathogen and then accumulate
throughout the transmission of
of this outbreak and analyzing snips for
outbreaks is something that we
routinely do however not in order um
to accomplish typing as no no
nomenclature can be associated easily to
to the snip phylogeny that that is the
result but
it is a very very powerful tool for
highly accurate source tracking so if
you want to establish
the chains of the transmissions and
trace pathogens
either back to the source or as i said
follow these
transmission chains then that is the
method that we routinely use
when we work with customers in the
epidemiology space
for instance dr materna i want to thank
you for your time today and for your
presentation would you like to provide
any closing remarks to our audience
before
we go i'd like to thank you all for
um for attending and for making the time
and taking the time out of your busy
schedules and
i'll look forward to receiving any other
questions that should arise at at a
later point in time
appearing in our inbox thanks again
everybody
and thank you again sir for your time
and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed
by the speaker via contact information
you provided at the time
of registration and i'd once
again like to thank dr materna for his
time today
and for his important presentation
and
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor opt-gen for underwriting today's
educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time take
care everyone
bye